this is a microwave oven it's like any
other microwave you've seen it's got a
clock it's got a start and stop button
and even has one of those round glass
plates that spins around real slow but
you know what the worst part of any
microwave is
it's the timer
the 60 seconds that you have to wait for
your hot pockets to heat up are the
longest 60 seconds in your entire life
and that's a fact
on the other hand i've put 60 hours into
video games before it
felt like 60 seconds i think the
solution here is obvious i'm gonna ditch
the stupid timer i'm gonna put a game
console in my microwave so that it heats
up food for as long as i can survive
a game of tetris what could possibly go
wrong
oh the screen just broke oh my god oh
the cheese didn't melt and i think the
cheese kind of was keeping the whole
thing together
oh there might be a couple flaws with
this my name is alan pan i'm an
electrical engineer and i build
ridiculous contraptions on youtube all
the time
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
today
the challenge is going to be getting a
retro game console
communicating with a microwave oven this
is of course
the venerable ching shiv fun for family
friends
classic empire retro portable player one
of the most anticipated console releases
for 2020.
let's go ahead and turn this on okay
some nice classic
8-bit uh title screen the music actually
turns off
and we get a menu here there are
apparently 182 games on this thing
it feels very light very cheap oh i've
actually
it looks like the screen just broke just
now so we want the microwave to only be
on
when i'm playing a game and to be off at
all other times
so i need to figure out a way to tell
when the game console is playing a game
and when it's
not now it sounds like it'd be pretty
simple but i feel like it might be
trickier than i think it is no matter
what round i take i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna have to use one of
these this is a microcontroller it's
basically a tiny computer that's easily
programmable this is probably gonna be
the brains of the operation
what i've noticed is when i'm playing a
game on this game console there's
background music playing but when i'm at
the selection menu to pick a game
there's actually no music at all i think
that might be
just good enough as an indicator of what
state the console's in
so if i use the microcontroller to
listen in on the sound that's being
played
i can just disconnect that speaker if i
plug that right into the microcontroller
that should give us
a rough idea when music is playing
because that music is really just going
to be
like a electrical waveform the
microcontroller is not going to care if
it's supposed to be music or if it's
just a signal so essentially we're just
going to say
that if there's music playing on this
thing we're playing a game
and if there's no music then we're not
playing a game and that's just going to
directly control the microwave oven
look here we go boom
microwave let's uh open it up and see
what's inside
something i want to point out is you
should not be taking apart microwaves at
home
and the way you know that is that this
microwave has these special
security screws they're like star-shaped
screws
with kind of a peg in the middle so even
if you have like star
drivers those aren't even what will
unlock these this is a screwdriver that
i found it's got a special bit
it's not the bit that was designed to
unscrew these safety screws but
it definitely is the one that we're
using for the job here it is the brains
and the muscle and you got to be really
careful not to touch any of this stuff
yet because
it's still uh they're parts that could
be electrically active and they'll kill
you pretty quick
they'll kill you pretty quick this metal
box here this is the magnetron this is
the part of the microwave that actually
generates the radial frequencies that
heats up your food
it does contain a ceramic called
beryllium oxide which
if we dropped it or cracked it or broke
it could generate a dust that
could kill us and this transformer down
here
which is this big block of metal is what
converts the voltage from our wall
outlets
into the high voltage required for the
magnetron and it does that in
conjunction
with this part here called a capacitor
and a capacitor stores electrical energy
and since we've used this microwave
already there's a decent chance that
this capacitor
still could be charged and if you touch
that wrong that can also kill you if
this capacitor is functioning correctly
then it should have actually discharged
itself over time
then we can go ahead and not have to
touch everything here with a plastic
action figure
to be extra safe we need to check the
voltage on this capacitor first
with what's called a multimeter a
multimeter can measure a lot of things
one of the things you can measure is the
voltage of a power source so we've got a
double a battery here and reading 1.6
volts which is normal for a new battery
if this capacitor is fully charged we
could read like 4 000 volts and what
we're really hoping for right now is
that i
see zero look at that it's perfectly
zero volts
this capacitor is doing its job it's
discharged itself
and it means that we are safe to go
ahead and touch stuff touch touch touch
so the microwave is open we need to
figure out how to connect
our game console to the microwave via a
microcontroller
in this part of the microwave it's on
the other side of the panel that's got
the clock and the start button and all
that stuff
this is where the brains of the
microwave are there's a chip here and
i'm
betting that that's a microcontroller
that's got all the programming for the
brains of this thing
but i'm interested in are these two
black boxes here and here these look
like relays to me and relays
are electromechanical switches so these
relays are turning something
on and off and if we look at these wires
they're coming off the relays and where
they lead to without wires going to the
lamp
the light in the microwave we've got
wires going to the fan the part of the
microwave that
cools the magnetron and we got wires
coming from these relays down to the
input
of this transformer i don't know if you
can see all the way down there there's
even wires going to the motor
that turns the glass table thingy what
we're gonna do is we're gonna replace
that relay
with a metal shim and we're just gonna
shove it in there
so it just acts like a wire so it'll be
a closed circuit the entire time
instead of a relay switching those
connections on or off these are now
permanently on
pro tip you never want to run a
microwave without something inside
to heat oh i didn't put the glass plate
in there
there we go oh is that
oh it's got to find it it's got a seat
correctly where's the thing
oh my gosh here's a pro tip you never
want to run a microwave
without something inside to heat because
otherwise
all that radial energy is just going to
bounce right back into the magnetron
and fry your microwave trust me i've
known people who've done it setting
their microwaves to use as a timer
without anything inside
don't do that just put a glass of water
in there i've got a power strip here
it's got an
on and off button so i'm going to plug
in the microwave and nothing should
happen
okay so theoretically as soon as i hit
this switch
the microwave should start microwaving
without me having to touch any of the
buttons or put in any time or anything
if my theory is wrong uh we might see
some fireworks
so let's see three two one hey
it's microwaving i can turn it off and
it's off
turn it on and it's on off
on up on that might not be a good part
i'll go ahead and leave that off
we can now control this entire device
with one simple
input output and if we use an arduino to
control our own relay that's connected
to the power supply that goes into the
microwave then we have a really easy way
of controlling this thing
so now all we have to do is figure out
how to get the arduino to listen to the
game console
this is where the power comes into the
microwave from the wall we got a white
wire we got a black wire
what we're going to do is we're going to
cut this black wire and we're going to
attach
a relay here which we know is an
electromechanical switch
this can be controlled with a
microcontroller and that's how we're
going to turn the microwave
on and off so now we just need to put on
three lead wires
there we go this is gonna go to the
arduino and that'll control the relay
and that'll control
the microwave bob's your uncle now i
just gotta drill a hole in the side of
this microwave
ah perfect missed all the vital organs
i don't know why everything i make ends
up looking like a bomb
not that i would ever make a bomb but if
i did
i would just make the wires all the same
color
here's a pro tip if you're going to be
sending wires out of a hole
of like a container or some kind of
packaging for your product
one easy thing to do is just tie a nice
little knot all that tension
gets stopped here and it doesn't go into
unplugging our wires
nice and secure
[Music]
we don't actually need to have any of
this stuff anymore because we're gonna
make a gaming microwave
so we can just go ahead and put the
hardware directly on top of the buttons
and display that we would normally use
we got double-sided foam mounting tape
for certain projects you can really get
away with using this to put like
90 of your stuff together breadboard
comes with its own double-sided mount on
the back
because they know you're just going to
be slapping this on something yeah
look at that that's secure we've got our
relay connected to the wall voltage
we've got our arduino here and that's
connected to the relay
and we've got this tablet connected to
the arduino i'm going to go ahead and
test it
so i'm going to tell our arduino to turn
the relay on
oh wait i need to actually stop this
because there's no cup of water in there
pro tip i literally just did a pro tip
about this how did i
doesn't matter we now have total digital
control over this microwave so
theoretically anything that acts as an
input to the microcontroller
could be used to turn this on or off i
mean it could be a tweet it could be
the stock market anything we can do
terrible things to this microwave now
now we just need to have this thing
somehow communicate
to this thing it looks like based off of
the cable they provided we've got
a video out and an audio out and we'll
be able to plug the
audio part of this into our micro
controller and tell
when music is playing
so the first thing i tried to do once
you know it the screen broke
very light very cheap oh it looks like
the screen just broke just now
so i figured you know what don't need
the screen because we'll have
this monitor here we can put this on the
microwave and we don't have to worry
about that
but then i was trying to grab the audio
from the rca audio
here and it turns out that this piece of
crap
doesn't have clean sound so what happens
is there's like this
crazy it's almost like a 60 hertz hump
there's just electrical noise up the
wahoo coming out this wire and so the
microcontroller can't tell the
difference between that and just sound
i tried to make like a bandpass filter
and you know what
it's been a long time since i've been in
college i haven't done that kind of math
and electrical engineering
in a while so we don't actually need any
of this
we don't need any of that none of it uh
because
we've got something much much better i
guess i'll show it to you now
after seeing how fragile our first game
console was there wasn't a chance in
heck i was gonna risk breaking our
second one so i just glued the thing
wholesale to our microwave the least
invasive way of telling when a game is
playing is to just glue a microphone to
the speaker hole so that's what i did
the microphone talks to the
microcontroller and i wrote some
programming do you want to see the code
i guess i could show you the code only
if you promise to look at it
there's a smoothing function so that it
doesn't accidentally discharge a
microwave so it's not too sad but that
doesn't matter right now what matters is
i've been filming
and i've been building and i have worked
up an appetite and i
want hot pockets
for one of these two minutes two minutes
that's an eternity but not if we're
playing a video game
the sleeve makes sure it cooks evenly
godspeed little hot pocket
uh i'll go ahead and turn on our game
controller
zero handicap come on i'm not a baby oh
geez that's actually really
fast boom oh yes this is working
we're doing it oh no i'm messing up now
i've made massive holes
so the game's over now that means our
microwave is done microwaving that was
about two minutes don't you think
let's see oh that's warm oh no wait oh
the middle's frozen
oh oh it's solid in the middle
oh god cause it's got meatballs
in theory i just need to be able to play
longer i just need to be a better gamer
and then i'll be able to have better
gamer food now i know what some of you
are thinking it's not safe to be playing
video games in front of a microwave door
for minutes on end
alright let's see how this works this
microwave door has a screen on the front
and it's a mesh
the diameter of those holes determine
what radio frequencies can pass through
them that means the microwaves cannot
actually get
past the screen even though it is full
of holes so it should be perfectly fine
to spend a couple of minutes sitting in
front of this microwave and uh playing
our lives away
now popcorn is kind of interesting
because it has like recommendations
for how long you're supposed to
microwave it for but it also says to
like listen for pops more than anything
so this is sort of like
the ideal gamer food for a gamer
microwave
because the time doesn't matter so i'm
gonna go a little bit easier on myself
now i'm gonna choose
the lowest difficulty setting and
that'll give us a chance to actually
cook this stuff hopefully
all right and we're starting here we go
oh look at this this is
block game for babies oh oh yes i just
got it oh
easy is so much easier than hard so
we are like peak popcorn right now and
this is normally
when dumb suckers would be looking at
the timer and pacing back and forth and
wondering if it was going to be done and
here we are
enjoying a nice game of falling block
game i can do this
all day it smells a little smoky i guess
now that i think about it
how long has the popcorn fit in there i
need to lose this game of tetris really
quick
game's over let's uh oh that's not a
good sign
oh okay oh my god
oh god it's stuck together
it's one solid i've never seen this
before
so pros of our microwave it certainly
does make you lose track of time
it's very very hard to tell how long
you're microwaving things for which was
the point
the cons are that it turns out
you actually do need to know how much
time you're spending microwaving food
one easter egg in uh our gamer microwave
here because it's a microphone
theoretically it'll pick up any loud
sound and i should be able to do this
well that was gamer microwave it kind of
worked i did it so that you don't have
to seriously don't try that at home
don't open your microwave at home i'll
see you next time gamers
a little still frozen and you can cut
right there